well new at 4 a new dmv campaign is  hoping to get more latinos on board  it's called ponte online on dmv or get  online with the dmv  and it's aimed at nevada's  spanish-speaking residents to use their  online services and kiosks  it also features a new facebook page to  serve hispanic customers directly since  according to the dmv  this population is rapidly growing i  think it's a really good time to reach  out to the hispanic community they are  29 percent of nevada's population and we  just need to do whatever we can to  remind people to use the online services  and the kiosks well the online portal  has expanded to allow nevadans without  a social security number to establish an  account this allows folks with a driver  authorization card to access  online address changes vehicle movement  permits and other services